have two separate categories you feel me
one is for fun and the other is for
wifey and you gotta understand that
those women who are wearing these short
dresses they're showing off their body
and all of that they all go into the fun
category like us man them we can you
know how okay let's put it this way that
women I'm sure you've all been in the
club before and a random guy approached
you and like you kind of can smell that
he's some kind of creep you feel me
right Magnum can do the same thing we
can smell when there's a hoe up like
talking to us can we not use this type
of terminology like can we not refer to
women as like hoes
I'm not asking can we use other words no
no but we're not we're not referring to
all women so I was referring to hoses
do we need to use that type of
vernacular
promiscuous women a man I would prefer a
man who took someone else's life is a
murderer right it doesn't matter what
you that you can try Dress It Up in any
way you can the fact is that Donny took
someone else's life now here's the thing
women now okay no let me put it a
different way humans right we all have
choices to make and one thing it's so
unfortunate but a lot of women to
struggle with the idea to understand
that your choices have consequences
right now take this in take this in
right you could be the most beautiful
woman in the world if you decide you
know what I'm gonna sell my body on only
fans guess what 95 of mandam are gonna
look at you and think you know what
you're beautiful you're cute but you're
an only fans so you're only gonna be in
the fun category do you understand like
there's a whole different category for
women who act a certain way who are
going to be taking as wifey material
exactly and there's a lot of women out
there who that they're living their best
life they're sorry that I was about to
swear by the effing a lot of random
right and then they're coming home at
the end of the day and think to
themselves why is no one committing
themselves to me men are territorial we
don't want women we're territorial
I'm not trying to talk about my
relationship too much but let me ask you
a question let me ask you a question
you have a brother I'm sure okay do you
want only one though okay is he older or
younger I'm the oddest so yeah he's
younger okay how old how old is John he
is
would you want him to date a girl that
slept with two of his friends
he did oh my god did you encourage me
it happened after they broke up okay it
happened happened after they broke up
and he was he was it really hurt his
face yeah yeah but I mean I mean okay
wait so wait let me get this straight he
dated a girl and then she slept with two
of his friends afterwards okay so so
you've seen firsthand the damage it can
do to a guy
okay again I don't like this word but um
but it describe you know what I'm saying
no I mean anyone would feel regardless
like anyone would feel a certain type of
way like you think that your
relationship you think your relationship
is going one way and then you realize oh
like that clay wasn't as valued valuable
for her as it was for him so that's
disappointing for sure but and again
like I understand that line of logic I
would feel quite similarly if I was
dating someone but again this I don't
like this I don't from my perspective I
don't like or enjoy conversation that is
dictating how women use their bodies but
then doesn't do the same thing for men
who are these like I I don't I that's
what I like if we're going to be having
conversations like okay what a woman How
would how how would a man feel if a
woman slept with multiple men I would
like to have the same conversation about
how a man the inverse of that so okay
I'll give you I'll give you I'll give
you the examples okay so again we can at
undo biology so would you agree that
like when women start running out of
time to have kids like they start to
think more about it if they want kids
right typically right because because
it's in the back think about it every
month right right right so but because
we can't undo our biology right so so
the closer like 90 of our eggs are gone
by 30. exactly so the closer we get to
30 we we start thinking about it more
right yes and it becomes more to the
Forefront of our mind okay so
historically men had to ensure paternity
there wasn't like there wasn't paternity
tests historically right and that's
that's new modern medicine so
if a man dated a girl that slept around
he wasn't he could potentially pass on
resources to a kid that was not his so
that's the biological reason why men
have evolved to not like girls that have
slept around however women it's the
opposite we have evolved two like men
that have slept around for example Drake
he's had a kid with a corn star
and he he clearly sleeps around yet
there are women lined up I mean so right
I okay there are factors that go into
that there's other factors but but you
understand my point right where Brittany
Renner or whatever the you know what I'm
talking Runner Brittany Runner there
aren't men and Mia Khalifa there are not
men lined up to date them they sleep
with them okay okay okay we're making a
lot of assumptions Okay Kevin Gates
turned it was smashed wait wait okay
okay you could argue I think I I think
you know deep down that men aren't lined
up to date them but if you want to
believe that but let me just tell you
the reason why so because if
historically we wanted a man that could
protect us and take care of us
financially yes so if he did that so
back back in the old days if I found a
guy that slept with you you and you then
I want him because oh he could protect
and take care of her her and her so I
want to get on that train so that's what
but we can't undo our biological Roots
so we still feel the way we feel about
it so you're saying that it this is the
second in summer summer is what you're
saying you're saying that when from a
perspective of a woman when I see a guy
who's been more promiscuous I will see
him biologically as a better provider
yes you you will be more attracted to
I'll give you an example have you ever
been have you ever been cheated on no no
have you ever been cheated oh wow I also
haven't been in a lot of relationships
so okay okay typically typically I girls
most girls that have been on my show
have been cheated on at some point
women like women that other women like
no no girl wants a guy that nobody wants
and I'll give you I'll give you a reason
why one it one in three men are either
virgins or haven't had sex in the past
year so if you wanted a guy that nobody
wanted there's a whole group one out of
three
but we don't want them
oh
did you get it
who has a guy in the friend zone like do
you know how many girls that listen I've
spoken to a lot of girls right and a lot
of girls have mandum in their friend
zone who would literally treat them the
best way any man would ever put it
down
they will give you everything you ever
wanted but guess what
ladies don't want us toxic mandum
wait wait wait wait go ahead go ahead
um I just wanted to to add to something
that you said earlier
um so uh so in in America uh being
raised uh in a black Christian family a
lot of women are raised with impurity
culture which if you're not familiar
with that it's it's essentially
um basically like God finds more value
in you when you maintain your virginity
yeah I went to Catholic School okay
um and so basically
um attached to that a lot of times is
also the idea that you lose value
um at the the more promiscuous you are
um which is you know but you see a
little bit of that in this conversation
that we're having but then you also have
the concept that like
um
uh all like men constantly want you uh
for sex and they constantly want you for
um as a sexual sexual object and there
are um specific even like passages in
the Bible that talk about like women who
were just taken like Angels by different
people right you know and they just get
taken because they were beautiful and
you know everybody had their way with
them and that's the story wait yeah wait
wait wait wait my point is my point is
that like sometimes I don't think people
realize this that it creates a mindset
of hypersexuality because sometimes as a
woman now you have to anticipate the
hypersexuality that you think a man is
going to have towards you and so you're
just kind of like oh we're having a nice
conversation they must want to have sex
with me you know and so so they do no no
yeah yeah so like like no man is is
going to want to date you if he doesn't
want to have sex no man's gonna want to
marry you if he doesn't want to have sex
most men that are nice to you want to
sleep
he's dating a woman right now yeah okay
okay okay now I have a question I have a
question I have a question what do you
want to do on your wedding night
I I guess my point was that like a lot
of men aren't uh bred almost like from
childhood to to anticipate someone
wanting to have sex with them like as as
a as the initial
point of contact in the relationship
whereas women are women are constantly
from like I can I can literally like
almost recite conversations that I had
when I was like in elementary school
where it was like by the way
growing up somebody's gonna somebody's
gonna want something for you and you
have to it's it creates a mindset of
anticipation which and creates a mindset
of hypersexuality which has this effect
that people are talking about but to me
to me I think that's honest that's true
men do want to have sex like again when
you when you hit 55 or whatever day your
looks go you know
um The World's Gonna treat you different
especially men men absolutely and women
talk about this when they're in their
late 50s 60s that like men treat you
that you get way less attention from men
but that I'm sorry that was in my point
my point is my Point's not on like the
attention that you're getting from them
my point is that like
uh I we were talking about like whether
or not
um
the body count thing yeah yeah like the
body count thing like whether or not a
man who has no bodies is attractive like
biologically whether I would be more
attracted to him or not like I I like I
would I would love to have like pursued
a relationship where we were both like
waiting until marriage it's just like
it's just not
it's it's just not common there aren't a
lot of men there there are it's one out
of three like trust me if you want a
virgin go down to Tesco
[Music]
it's like it's like it's like okay
Walgreens let's go to Walgreens that's
hilarious go to Walgreens look at look
at the man behind the counter about five
six five seven that's so funny
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible